let's get started with some problems
let's see first problem what is what is
15 percent of 40 the way I do percent
problems is I just convert the
percentage to a decimal and then I
multiply it times the number that I'm
trying to get the percentage of so 15
percent as a decimal is 0.15 you learned
that from before the percent to decimal
conversion a video hopefully and we just
multiply this times 40 so let's say 40
times 51 5 5 times 0 is 0
5 times 4 is 20 bring down put a 0 there
and then 1 times 0 is 0 1 times 4 is 4
and you get 6 0 0 then you count the
decimal spots 1 2 no decimals up there
so you go 1 2
you put the decimal there so 15 percent
of 40 is equal to 0.15 times 40 which
equals 6 point 0 0 well that's just the
same thing as 6 let's do another problem
hopefully that didn't confuse you too
much and I'm going to try to confuse you
this time just in case you weren't
properly confuse the last time what is
0.2 percent of let me think of a number
of 7 so a lot of people's inclinations
would just say 0.2 percent that's the
same thing as 0.2 and if that was your
inclination you would be wrong because
remember this isn't point two this is
0.2% so there's two ways of thinking
about this you could say that this is
0.2 over 100 which is if you multiply
the numerator and the denominator by 10
is the same thing as two over a thousand
or you can just do the technique where
you move the decimal space over two to
the left in which case if you're
starting with point two you need to move
the decimal space two to the left you go
BAM whoops
bam bam and that's where the decimal
goes so it's point zero zero two this is
key point two percent is the same thing
as point zero zero two this can always
trip you up and I've made this careless
mistake all the time so don't feel bad
if you ever do it but just always play
careful attention to decimal and a
percentage at the same time so now that
we figured out how to write this
percentage as a decimal we just have to
multiply it times the number that we
want to take the percentage of so we say
point zero zero two times seven well
this is pretty straight forward 7 times
2 is 14 right and how many total numbers
do we have well how many total digits do
we have behind the decimal point
let's see it's one two three so we need
one two three digits behind the decimal
point so 0.2 percent of seven is equal
to point zero one four and you're
probably thinking boy that's a really
really small number and and it makes
sense because 0.2% that's if you want to
think about it that's smaller than even
1% so that's even smaller than one
hundredth and actually if you think
about it point two percent is one five
hundredths so and if you do the math
seven one five hundreds of seven will
turn out to be this number and that's
that's an important thing to do it's
always good to do a reality check
because when you're doing these decimal
and these percent problems it's very
easy to kind of lose a factor of ten
here they are gained a factor of ten so
always do a reality check to see if your
answer makes sense so now I'm going to
confuse you even further what if I were
to ask you for is 20%
of what number number so a lot of
people's reflux we might just be oh let
me take 20 percent it becomes 0.20 and
multiply it times 4 and in that case
again you may be wrong because think
about I'm not saying what is 20% of 4
I'm saying the 20% of some number is 4
so now we're going to be doing a little
bit of algebra I bet you didn't expect
that in the percent module so let X
equal the number the number or this
number let X equal that number and this
problem says that 20 percent 20 percent
of X is equal to 4 I think now it's in a
form that you might recognize so how do
we write 20 percent of the decimal well
that's just point 200 or 0.2 and we just
multiply it by X to get 4 so 20 percent
that's the same thing as 0.2 it's same
thing as point 2 oh but that last
trailing zero doesn't mean much 0.2
times X is equal to 4 and now we have a
level 1 linear equation but you didn't
expect to see that so what do we do we
we can either well there's two ways to
view it you can just divide both sides
of this equation by the coefficient on X
so if you divide point 2 here you divide
by 0.2 here so you get X is equal to 4
divided by 0.2 so let's figure that what
4 divided by 0.2 is see I hope I have
enough space 0.2 goes into 4 I'm going
to put a decimal point here and the way
we do these problems we move the decimal
point here 1 over to the right so we
just get a 2 and we can move the decimal
point here 1 over to the right so this
point 2 goes into for the same number of
times that 2 goes into 40 and this is
easy
two goes into 40 how many times well 2
goes into 4 two times and then 2 goes in
zero zero times you can done that in
your head - and 240 is 20 times
so 4 divided by 0.2 is 20 so the answer
is 4 is 20 percent of 20 and does that
make sense well there's a couple of ways
to think about it 20% is roughly what it
is exactly 1/5 and right 4 times 5 is 20
that makes sense if you and still not
sure we can check the problem let's take
20 percent of 20 so 20 percent of 20 is
equal to 0.2 times 20 and if you do the
math that also will equal 4 so you made
sure you got the right answer
let's do another one like that I'm
picking numbers randomly let's say 3 is
9 percent of what so if X once again
let's let X equal the number the number
that 3 is 9 percent of you don't have to
write all that well in that case we know
that 0.09 X right point oh 9s assume
things 9 percent of X is equal to 3 or
that X is equal to 3 divided by 0.09
well if we do the decimal division 0.09
goes into 3 let's put a decimal point
here I don't know me 0 so I'm going to
need so if I move this decimal over to
the right twice then I'll move this
decimal over to the right twice so 0.09
goes into 3 the same number of times
that 9 goes into 300 so 9 goes into 30 3
times 3 times 9 is 27 I think I see a
pattern here already
33 3 away 9 is 27 you're just going to
keep getting 33333 the threes are just
going to go on forever so it turns out
that 3 is 9
percent of you could either write it as
thirty three point three repeating or we
all know that point three forever is the
same thing as 1/3 so three is nine
percent of 33 and 1/3 either one of
those would be an acceptable answer a
lot of times when you're doing
percentages you're actually just trying
to get a ballpark so the precision might
not always be the most important thing
but in this case we will be precise and
obviously on tests and things you need
to be precise as well hopefully I didn't
go too fast and you have a good sense of
percentage the important thing for these
type of problems is pay attention to how
the problem is written if it says find
you know ten percent of a hundred that's
easy you just convert ten percent to a
decimal multiplied 100 but if I were to
ask you 100 is ten percent of what you
have to remember that that's a different
problem in which case 100 is ten percent
of and if you did the math it would be a
thousand I think I spoke very quickly on
this problem on this on this module so I
hope you didn't get too confused but I
will record more